[موسيقى]
من المؤكد أنها صحراء
ولكن في الفيلم كانت
حرب النجوم المريخ ومنزل علاء الدين ،
وهي صحراء وادي الرام في الأردن حيث
حدثت إحدى أعظم لحظات التاريخ في
عام 1916 ، انضم ضابط بريطاني إلى
تحالف من المتمردين العرب الذين
ثورة ضد الإمبراطورية العثمانية
كانت الولادة المبكرة للمملكة الهاشمية
وأصبح ذلك الضابط البريطاني معروفًا باسم
لورنس أراغون
[موسيقى] تم
تخليده في الفيلم في عام 1962
[موسيقى]
تم إعادة إنشاء الهجوم العربي الشهير بعناية
هذه الأيام من قبل الأردن
شركة إحياء
التراث يديرونها أسبوعيًا للسائحين ،
لقد تعاملت مع كل شيء
بنفسي ،
نحن لسنا بعيدين عن المحطة حيث
بدأ الهجوم وبدأ الهجوم ونعود
إلى عام
1916. الكثير من العمل الشاق  لقد ذهبنا إلى فهم
هذا الأمر بشكل صحيح من الناحية
التاريخية ، فنحن نعرف كيف تنتهي هذه القصة
من فوز الثوار العرب بالحرس
، ويتم أسرني
جيدًا إذا كان هذا هو ما حدث ، فمن الأفضل أن
أنزل من القطار في اتجاه واحد أو ر  wo
عندما أخذني كرهينة ذهب من أجلها
بحماسة ،
أعني
أنني حاولت أن أبتسم كما لو كنت أقول إن كل
شيء ممتع ، أليس كذلك
ولم يفعل
[موسيقى]
إنه إنتاج يستحق الشاشة
الكبيرة وليس من المستغرب  ظهر هذا القطار
في العديد من الأفلام التي
يتذكرها صاحب السمو الملكي الأمير علي
منذ وقت سابق
، وقد انضم إلي الآن في وادي رم ،
وهو يريد أن يمنحني جولة في الجزء
الخلفي من فيلم هوليوود الذي يتم إنتاجه في
الأردن ،
ولا يمكننا تحديد الفيلم الذي
لماذا  هل هو مهم للأردن جيدًا
إنه أه مهم بمعنى
أننا نقوم بتطوير صناعة الأفلام الخاصة بنا
ولكنه أيضًا يجلب
فوائد حقيقية أه للناس إنه يتعلق
بالأشخاص الذين يعملون على الأرض
وتستفيد المجتمعات المحلية منهم جميعًا  هذه
الصناعة الرائعة والناس يربطونها
بهذا هو العالم الحديث الذي
يريد الناس رؤيته وهم يريدون أن
يتخيلوا أنهم يريدون أن يفهموا
أه ما يحدث
هذا هو بالضبط المكان المناسب لي لإنهاء
وقتي في الأردن
كم مرة أتيت إلى هنا
جيدًا أنا  تعال إلى هنا بقدر ما
أستطيع ، الصحراء مكان جميل إنه
نظيف إنه نقي
إنه مكان يمكنك فيه تجديد نشاطك
في هذا العالم هذا العالم المجنون الذي نعيش
فيه حيث كل شيء ،
فكيف تقول إنه
سريع الخطى إنه من الجيد  عد إلى أصولك
ما يحدث
داخل
الأمير علي
عندما يأتي إلى هنا وينظر إلى
ما يحدث داخل جزيرة الأمير
لدينا كلمة
باللغة العربية ويطلق عليها sekina
sekina وتعني
سلام القلب قطعة
السلام في روحك
و  هذا ما تشعر به
أنك تنظر إلى
عالم لانهائي ، عالم لانهائي
، مكان لانهائي وهذا ما نشعر به
[الموسيقى]
الذي قد يفشل في
الإعجاب وأعتقد أن الأمير علي قد أعطاني
الكلمة التي تصف كل هذا على أفضل
وجه  sukina
سلام الروح الهدوء الذي
نسعى إليه جميعًا
وسوف ترغب في العثور على السكينة الخاصة بك
عند زيارتك لأنه بدون
شك رجل وأردن جزء من
عالم العجائب
[الموسيقى]
أنت